if you didn't borrow my money to buy me
a gift I would totally miss the fact
that you love me so love it don't leave
that out cut don't leave that out when
I'm hanging out with my dad
it feels like I'm hanging out with older
version of myself I'm from a family of
all women and then here comes
Christopher
yeah anything original everything
original started with us we're the old
G's and so that is the reason why we get
loud we just not gonna sit around and
just let y'all outdo us we going out big
[Music]
hanging out with my dad is just a lot of
fun I mean we've done everything from
horseback riding to bowling hey just
hanging out the crib we grocery shop a
lot to be honest like this one thing we
really do it all depends on what son I
get cuz Chris is moody for the most part
high school baseball or college baseball
we're always filming with each other the
greatest the joy and excitement for me
hanging out with Jared is that we hang
out as friends
now looking back on and now it just
seems like a rite of passage for a
father to cut his sons hair the haircut
itself I I don't really know what to say
about that growing up he always made it
a big deal that I brushed my hair always
lotion or deodorant I just always
remember him he's an old spice when we
were growing up always like seeing the
bottles and the fragrance always was
just this strong like you know manly
fragrance that always just kind of like
associated with him it's a mix of the
old school and the new school after
baseball practice of basketball practice
whenever you would get in a car he would
smell like that sport now that was
definitely a moment you could have used
some whole spice yeah one of the best
things he ever time a can honestly say
was you might be broke but you don't
need to smell like it or look like and
that's what it kind of made me get into
having colognes and you know wearing
body sprays it's beautiful I smell I
smell you sea spray I notice your
favorite okay dad so listen I have a
surprise for you and it is for Father's
Day
and trust me I use my own money what
what
boom Old Spice sea spring this is what
you need right here
we often say it but it's not so much the
actual words I love you but I would
listen to him as his son let him voice
his dissent if he disagreed the most
covenant thing that we have is a
handshake this telling my body don't
show it just ugly just wondering when he
saved my dude and bring it in and then
we stand in chest the chest is closed so
there's a lot of finger moving in there
if your hands away they feel kind of
gross but he showed me everything my
camera equipment as far as like giving
me tips on like what I should use and my
opinion that's the biggest I love you
possible
[Music]
yes that you are literally my hero
if I could be a small percentage of the
men that I've seen you beat both on
stage and off I would be well above the
rest so happy Father's Day to you
[Music]